[Music]
parents students and teachers are
eagerly preparing classrooms in mexico's
guerrero state for a return to in-person
classes
for the last 18 months thomas alva
edison elementary school in the
outskirts of acapulco has remained
closed the effort underway is to have
the facility up and running by the
august 30th back-to-school deadline
i hope we can return to classes so that
our children can study and have an
interest in their education because it's
not the same to study at home
though everyone is lending a hand many
here are worried the effort may not be
enough parents say the facility lacks
many basic necessities like sanitation
supplies and at times even running water
the school needs many things as you can
see even the wooden windows are rotting
away
coronavirus contagion is still quite
high in this part of mexico and so are
concerns over going back to school
we have to get the school in good
condition with good ventilation and
enough space as you can see the
classrooms are quite small
social distancing is complicated
the reopening of schools has been a
divisive issue in mexico sparking
protests against the government where
many claim authorities have mismanaged
the response to the pandemic
this demonstration in downtown mexico
city was organized by students and their
parents many of whom say they want a
return to in-person classes but are
concerned that the mexican government
cannot guarantee the safety of students
government statistics suggests more than
5 million children have dropped out of
school during the pandemic children's
rights organizations also point to other
alarming trends like a 24 increase in
cases of domestic abuse
international organizations like unicef
and the who say fears over contagion are
warranted but also warn of the negative
impacts the last year and a half has had
on children and adolescents
we believe the risk of reopening schools
is lower than the risks children and
adolescents are already running by
keeping them out of school education is
not only about knowledge it's about
learning social skills it's a question
of development it's a matter of reaching
one's potential in life and we have to
prioritize this
though most schools in mexico began
welcoming students on monday morning
many others have decided not to reopen
thomas alva edison elementary in
guerrero state is among those choosing
to keep their doors closed until
coronavirus contagion rates in the state
are adequately reduced
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city